alors si vous kiffez les matches entre
communautés met un petit pouce bleus sûr
sur youtube en tout cas nous on est très
bonne humeur la sur le stream
on est très très bonne humeur et on se
lance on fait des cadeaux à kiev si je
veux changer cinq noeuds là on va on sur
un peu le match j'ai mis le classement
j'ai mis un peu allez on va on va
remettre le design montrouge à nantes
hier janvier chéquier bon du monde et on
va l'ont fait une petit rond peuvent ce
qui m'est complètement dans la détente
totale et il fait ces six banques et f3
dégage avec ton cavaliers damas un à
faire ces trois et d'amis 6 1
j'étais du fer qui a aidé de moins faire
flouer f2 je rappelais plus trop de
cette variante on sent que c'est pas
terrible pour les blancs mais bon bah on
va faire ce qu'on peut hein pas
développé tranquille il joue vite le
petit ch'ur peut-être faire 3 f 4 1
comme un comme un stonewall
du coup ils m'empêchent on va faire 3
quand même un peu une poubelle là non
peut-être que sur ces 6 il faut jouer un
autre coup j'ai raison que dans ces
trucs par communauté j'ai tout le temps
des poubelles en fait je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'ai pas mangé tout le temps
des poubelles
ce remake se prépare avant je pense
qu'il faudrait alors qu'en coach s
league ça va plus ou moins mais non ce
truc par communauté c'est vraiment la
catastrophe à la alors je vais peut-être
faire f 4 cavaliers f3 si je peux
je sais que c'est un peu pourri niveau
structure j'ai le pion au 3 quai mal
mais bon du coup raison que j'ai tout
reprend d un jeu le chiffre est ce que
j'ai tout reprendre et un toit j'ai pris
peur 3 j'aimerais diriger vers eux 5
avec le cavale je ne fais un petit coup
de hache 3 anticipé cavaliers 6 bon on
va voir
ce patois par la position mais bon je
monte un petit tour en c1 ou pas est ce
que je vais faire un petit coup de
cavaillon qui s'y prend je prends jean
vainqueur en effet 3 je suis mal de
partout il à la paire de fou c'est
horrible
il a la paire de fou c'est horrible
c'est peut-être faire tour c'est un fou
mais cette fois f5 cavaliers f6 qui a eu
5 mai il y aura ces cinq à ce moment là
on va tenter quand même et j'ai de
nouveau une poubelle je sais pas comment
je fais dans ce truc là j'ai toujours
des poubelles intergalactique
j'ai toujours des poubelles en terre
avec intergalactique dans ce truc là
mais ouais je sais 6 du coût total froid
c'est pas terrible
ok où il fait sage est une jeune tour en
j'ai tellement une poubelle
intergalactique
c'est la galère parce qu'on est une
option ou iii est faible qui a valu à 5
c'est pas top top j'ai peut-être faire
quand même
j'ai de nouveau une poubelle
intergalactique
il va prendre je vais prendre
j'ai un truc très chiant à jouer
ce qu'en fait il va peut-être me prendre
du cavage apprendre du pion il va bouger
le fou insérons du cac à ce truc
ok il paraît que lecavalier
ok le truc c'est du coup j'ai bien envie
de faire fou j'ai quatre parties avec le
carillon détroit je vais essayer de
faire ça
faire ça fout g46 fef si je suis
cavaliers ici et sur fois ici je suis
tour d'être autour c3 et je remets la
tour là et je mettrai le cavalier
quelque part est en fait du kung fu
angers 4 pour éviter de me prendre un g6
et que le fonds puisse pas retenir
repartir qui est fait c'est 5 pour du
coup j'ai bien envie de mettre le fou en
f3 paraît bien placé le fond f3 parce
qu'au moins je revis ça mon peut-être
suis en train de faire un peu de
pas de magie parce que magie magie votre
vision du génie mais donc c'est pas nous
c'est pas de la main du voilà je fais
pas des cubes maggi la met
mais peut-être que je suis en train de
l'embrouillé un peu quoi peut-être pas
si clean que ça ce qu'il fait après il
peut faire rassurer fils et peut-être
cassé quatre ici mais puis on prend ces
quatre ans baissait à turin n'a en fait
le problème c'est qu'il arrive si ce qui
est des trois essais 4 et je suis prêt
de repartir vers eux un don kent ont ils
fait pas ça
ce que je suis cavagnan c4 puis on prend
fou prend j'ai envie juste qu'ayant c4
menacé le fouquet et 17 qui ait eu 5
je vais essayer de faire ça c'est un peu
court parce que si je me suis planté
dans le calcul ça craint mais sinon je
fais tout en restant romanesque que je
fais des trucs quoi bon niveau du score
on mène 1 0 pendant que je vais prendre
une fois et je vais me ramener de
nouveaux ici j'ai pas à quel point je
[Musique]
j'ai quand même l'impression de
alors ça c'est un peu chiant
ah ça c'est un peu chiant pour la peine
parce qu'ils jouent como pion aux trois
qui est super mal paraît surtout re 1
il peut me jouer f6 qui est des 3b 4 et
j'ai plus de casse pour le cavalier
masse assez pénible sa rage et les
pièces qui sont mal placés à un truc
près et sinon j'ai un truc à le truc en
h4 aussi qui est pénible prendre c'est
hors de question
c'est pénible ça alors je mette sept
tours ici sur f6 ferké et détroit est
sûre ça met le quai en c1 mais bon et
après faire qu'à eux deux quais c3 mais
mon de base c'est pas du tout ce que je
comptais faire aux questions je peux
peut-être prendre ici il prend du pion
il peut pas prendre du fou effet retour
des 1 et sur f
il suit réussi ce qui est des trois à
quoi que j'aurais cavale et b4 parce que
le foot pas prendre mais bon est-ce que
si je prends y prend jamais la tour en
d1 il fait f6
gk et détroit il fait ses cartes chèques
et b4 il fait trop froid qui est
présente est là je prend peut-être je
prends une frange fait tourner un ff xi
check et détroit il bouffe je bouffe
j'ai un peu de contre eux je peut-être
parce qu'en fait j'ai mes pièces qui
sont quand même bien placé pour ce truc
là
j'aimerais position et puante un conte
ce soyons d'accord mais en fait j'ai
envie de profiter du fait que ces pièces
soit un peu ce que si la position
s'ouvre et qui fait je la perds deux
fous concurrents 3 c'est fini je peux
abandonner sa place et s'est
complètement vérifiable le texan en
train de verser fait complètement
n'importe quoi ok j'ai géré la situation
et du coup j'ai juste envie de profiter
du placement de casser du coup sûr c'est
car j -b 4 la chance autant prêts quoi
j'aurais attaque ça où je me fais
peut-être qualifié 5-1 et qu'ils
daignent j'attaque ça je bouffe bougez
vous savez peut-être que je passe un peu
par part et en mène 5-3 fossat faut
qu'on s'accroche les mecs sains faut
vraiment s'accrocher on n'est pas
sérieux par rapport aux coffres n'est
pas si mal au qui prend là on crée donc
je prends ces 5
franchement j'ai l'impression que je que
je gère la génération des géants
brouillée l'an brouillade ah ok il part
par là bas ok alors maintenant there are
to school
il ya deux écoles j'ai envie de tenir on
parle anglais ici faites attention ces
francophones anglophones de langues
alors l'idée c'est qu'ils surfent ou
prend des saints qui veut prendre
prendrait plus une tour en e2 mais en
fait j'ai envie de lui faire un truc
j'ai envie de faire f 5 qui avait lieu 6
cm coup il ya ma femme qui est en train
d'arriver fait gaffe il m'a frappé en
train d'arriver à l'est russophone
faites gaffe ya ma femme qui arrive elle
va être contre nous les mecs on ne dit
plus un mot il n'y a plus un mot sur ce
stream décalre entre nous tu ce bouche
cousue on ne dit plus rien faut faire
très attention là on à l'ennemi qui
arrive
l'ennemi ouvre la porte de chez moi
attention attention les mecs plus un mot
on ne dit plus rien vous prend des cinq
points des cinq points des cinq tours ne
crois j'ai trois tours prend b2 qui est
des scènes dont je la sens pas trop
j'aime pas cette tour qui arrive sur la
deuxième
notre côté ce pion là il a du mal à le
défendre mais f5 céleste ou machin g4
j'aime pas je peux aussi faire des
quatre pour me libérer le cavalier
à la rigueur je peux faire tous ces deux
je peux faire tour ces deux aussi s'y
prend prend ses 5 c'est pas grave
ouais je vais faire tourner ses 2
tout en n'étant pas complètement sûrs
d'eux si c'est bien ou pas
pour les mecs faut que vous vous
accrochez on est peut-être à son hymne
et 9,5 là tout d'un coup ah mince les
mais qu'est ce qui nous arrive là à
rennes on a des petits derrières faut
vraiment que l'ukrainien il fasse
quelque chose hein ok ils jouent ça
c'était peut-être pas bon le tour c'est
d'heure c'était peut-être pas bon le
tour ces deux on peut faire j'ai trois
là mes affaires g5
et si je fais f5 pour aller jouer g4
comme je voulais le faire tout à l'heure
bon allez on part pour ça mais je suis
pas confiant
ouais mais la tour ans et d'aller
peut-être pas mal placé car dans
certaines variantes et surtout re5 g4 et
on veut mettre le cavalier e 6 ça fait
du sens avec ta torrentielles du coup et
ça s'explique pas ce que c'est on peut
vouloir jouer tour d2 pour doubler mais
c'est que ce qui est pas mal c'est
surtout re5 g4g 6 accueilli 17 cavaliers
f6 échec et qu'il prend des cinq du coup
là c'est lara zada et qu'il prend 1,8
aussi le cavalier de mazaugues le
paradis venez tous un condo tant donné
et mais quand on fait un gros début de
match on est bien aïe aïe aïe ya des
gens qui sont défoncés là les mecs sains
il ya des gens qui sont défoncés il ya
des gens qui dans le chatt parle
beaucoup mais qui sur l'échiquier
n'assume pas monsieur pessoa par exemple
il assume ip choi y gagne ça là je dis
bravo monsieur pessoa je dis bravo
monsieur pessoa il fait tout sous la
pression sous la pression de sa femme
qui était proche il devait il faut que
je fasse faut que je lâche un résultat
sur des échecs ça va se voir que je vous
pose échec
c'est sûr ça laisse voir à force à aller
voir ailleurs fait le boulot au moins
alors il peut faire pousser cette qui me
fait un peu chier mais qui défoule et 6
ça je vous le dis franchement ça me fait
chier de fond est celle qui est aussi
sous b ici c'est à ces rôles ou sap
la paire de fou c'est toujours chiant de
façon
la lettonie 2 0 alors attendez il est où
eytan et hans qui gagne 2,0 chef de cf
sonne sonne il a battu 2-0 écouter et
anne qui est chaud est animé les points
mais peut-être su repousser cette gti 17
bizarrement j'empêche fou mais ici c'est
je veux prépare à vous fait des cinq
mois je le mets un peu en sueur le jour
nicolas et là je fais le chat je suis là
et là on joue contre les russes on sent
qu'il ya des filles assez mignonne dans
l'équipe d'en face on est chaud là on
est comme des morts de faim avant ce
match on est bouillant l'ena mais moi je
vous contre un mec mais la table d'à
côté une fille yulia on va voir s'il ya
des gens dont le tchad qui réussissent à
tu as à avancer leurs pions j'ai envie
de dire pour rester dans le thème
échiquier un tu as je tâcherai champs
les champs chant lyrique à l'échec
avancer leurs pions
mais est ce que tu vois la métaphore
ouais tu as tu y avancer sa tour toi tu
pensais tu entend appuyer une tourtois
incroyable incroyable je te laisserai
jamais faire un stream sur ma chaîne
jamais mais jamais les allusions alors
mais alors bonjour comment avancer leurs
pions bon tu vois je leur s'approcher à
toi boom la tour quoi tout de suite oh
là là cet esprit mal placé les gens à
ses quelque chose alors là c'est malin
parce que si je prends il fait fou g3 et
tour eu un match
donc ça faut reconnaître que c'est malin
bon je peux faire tout reprendre et 4 je
peux faire tout reprendre et 4 il prend
part en prend ouais je vais faire tout
reprendre et 4 je fais tout reprendre et
4 à vif
j'ai la flemme de calcul est incroyable
chant lyrique alphand lexical wim on ne
sait pas ok bon il fait ça il fait tout
re 2 e et et il va prendre b2 mais c'est
pas sûr parce qu'il a fait retour de roy
j'ai trois tours b 2 je vais faire tour
c'est cette île aura pas le temps de
faire tout re 2 j'aurais tour des huit
matchs je suis là quand même je suis
encore là je suis encore dans le game
les gens disent que tu es coquine dans
le chat et tours devra g3 franchement
tour de je suis pas sûr parce que tour
prend b2 je fus camus faire un petit
tour 17 ours et 7 je ne suis pas décidé
encore laquelle si on ne fait pas grand
chose est desséchée page contrôler un
pion je suis pas sûr de tours 2 je pense
qu'il aima le petit nicolas a échoué à
prendre tes final j'ai envie de tenir il
ya quand même la paire de fou de base il
était mieux bon il peut faire tout
recettes mais je vais faire bk du
l'avancé
nicolas y furent enfants sueur devant la
technique du joueur français
c'est tendu s'est tendue c'est en y en a
on est en train de miner le joueur russe
là je pense la russie en sueur devant le
talent des joueurs français il mène 22 à
7 dans l'autre côté on est mal mais 74
ni qui a peut-être eu un peut-être
quelque chose de bizarre la part de
carlos eva attention on ne sait pas
bon je pense un jour mais aussi je peux
faire cette tour là pour à l'idée de
faire tout rejet carette mai mais je
pense qu'en fait c'est tellement fort de
faire ça et ça
ok qui couvre la septième ce qui est
hyper logique
mais ce que je peux faire un échec roy
ici et tour ici et je passe par derrière
pour jouer les maths
ouais je crois que c'est pas mal souvent
tir monté avec la tour je vais faire
tourner des scènes dansées 7 machin tôt
mais c'est vrai je suis pas sûr
j'ai 5
ça j'avais pas vu
ça j'avais point vue voilà
d'ajouts et ouvrages fuite
roy g7 tour j'ai huit meilleurs bref
cette le retour
bref cette le retour sur quoi je serais
tourbe et 8 quand même un machin
on
non ok
j'aurais regardé si je peux pas le
réseau t'aimer
ces ultimes m'en fout quoi
quelques jours peut-être faire à 4
maintenant je vais peut-être faire échec
ça échec ça et cheikh sarr et attendez
je vais faire échec ça échec ça échec
ça sera encore un échec
mais j'arrive pas le maté pour le moment
un jeu peut faire tour ici puis on prend
un tour à je suis tu m'as tu as assez
joli si ça marche c'est super beau si ça
marche c'est super bowl aux joueurs
français dominent le jeu
franchement si tu fais ça les mecs c'est
vachement beau je vais débat ça pour
rien que pour vous faire chier je vais
la mettre sur facebook je vais la mettre
je vais faire très belle tactique du
joueur français
ma charge en chemin elle est belle
franchement les super belle cette
tactique ça va mettre d'oberhof en sueur
degroof su c'est super joli ton g6 âge
proche des six tours à je suis de maths
est sûre et sur h6 je mate aussi
mais c'est pas encore complètement fini
mais vraiment c'est super joli ça
c'est un échec il va faire froid là je
vais faire tout rejet 4g lastours h4
matt bim bim la russie en sueur poutine
su quoi poutine su et sur afficher les
tours à la suite non franchement c'était
joli
franchement c'est très joli non
franchement faut faut reconnaître non
mais vraiment un pareil aura dans le
chatt j'espère que vous êtes en sueur de
beauté un nom mais honnêtement
sauf que là c'est un prix de beauté
international de tous les deux tout les
voilà faut le savoir à ses très belles
combinaisons là c'est du très haut
niveau là c'est vous tous rêvent si ce
machin tour g6 franchement c'est le beau
jeu à laver mais moi je me choque mais
moi tu vois je pensais pas être au
niveau pour trouver des trucs comme ça
là si on dit nîmes dovic l'a fait wayne
selimovic alors là c'est chaud game of
the year non mais vraiment vraiment là
t'as lafitte qui est déjà en train
attend de voir si un jsms jsms de rex
signe que field donc président du grand
duché ce tour qui m'écrit kiev est ce
que tu viens jouer le tout ce que tu
prends la wild card pour le prochain
grand duché ce tour bon je lui réponds
non rex franchement ballack de ton
tournoi quand tu fais des partis comme
ça c'est plus le grand duché ce tour
c'est c'est le world tour
c'était g qui avait servi de mâcon sms
de macron mais je les fais là c'est bon
j'ai tout de suite tu vois j'ai j'ai
bloqué le numéro i ll be my man u peux
plus m'en voyez de peut plus envoyer de
sms à sa sauce et c'est fini cette
histoire là je ne plus recevoir de sms
wall e kévin chasse tour voilà c'est ça
je lui réponds ça je vois qu'on doit
être renommé le cabinet chasse tour un
message vous êtes tellement sûr devant
cette beauté ce matéco plus digne d'une
recette gastronomique del pueblo ce
matin
et là on peut dire que tant sur devant
la gastronomie del pueblo rhin le genre
t'as regardé la vidéo très attentivement
du burger avec la galette devions en
dessous ouais bah mais je leur faut le
dire au bout d'un moment
atreg trébouta très goûteux alors qu'est
ce qui me fait ils envoient un pion
ce
moi je peux moi je peux tout faire un
lieu ouvert à tous oui car oui dans mes
fait moi aussi mais qu'est ce que tu
veux nous faire un tuto sandwich et n'a
pas je crois que l'ena voudrais faire un
tuto sandwich mais mais peut-être pour
un autre stream allez on va faire pour
des huit alors demandé ou au score on
est mené 30 à 10 cm et franchement je me
décarcasse à faire des prix de beauté à
donner des leçons et on se fait défoncer
et franchement les mecs
franchement les mecs c'est abusé on
écoute et moi sont fous il me saoule là
j'en ai marre j'en ai marre de ces
pièces à quai ce qui me fait enfin non
je suis écoeuré les mecs
je suis même v6 nom n'a pas n'a pas le
même niveau on a la même passion speed
and après à les cailloux 5
c'est un clouage à a alors là il en
sueur bilan sur la ion riches ou en
sueur nicolas et florence mailhot
richard c'est nikolay attention ne
seront pas de prénom s'il vous plaît un
peu de décence comme incroyable nous
avons des invités de russie nous
trompons de prenons alors est ce qu'on
fout le bordel
est ce qu'on fout plus de bordel au
bordel vous savez que j'aime bien foutu
bordel au bordel ça me fait marrer et du
coup j'avais envie de faire acheter ce
qui me paraissait bien goûtu mais ça me
fait un peu peur mais h6 ça rajoute du
bordel au bordel dans le premier cinq
food et si ce n'est sur kaia 4 puis on
prend
c'est tellement la merde attendez je
vais faire à justice mais c'est le
bordel 1 et 6 fait qu'il ya qu'a tu peux
prendre ici quand même parce que
j'attaque la dame
j'ai raté un truc ou pas
il n'y a que deux matches par temps avec
deux parties m cédric se marcher dessus
ah il prend les pièces
il est malin et a pris trois pièces pour
la dame
moi je me bats avec le roi pour
commencer comme ça j'aime être le pion à
f si ce n'est un peu me blinder
mais quelle idée 5 20 kg est bon je
serai dame c6 et tf6 f
je suis inquiète les mecs
après je fais aussi max fait de folies
en prenant des cinq prenant b2 mais je
vais avoir beaucoup de matos de retard
si je fais ça général je suis concentré
là je peux pas tout faire
j'entre en jeu contre un de tes
compatriotes c'est pas une partie de
plaisir il est du genre relou
goethe est mal en fait la 3e suite
c'était vraiment un coup de chiottes
[ __ ] je suis nul
si je fais dame sait si ça va être là
l'horreur quoi elle qui a vallier qui
rentrent faut que je me stabilise la
faut que juste amèneront tour prend des
singes l'arcouade retard et j'ai tour de
pièges et prendre b2 genre 1 2 3 4 53 5
il peut taper un pion de gens tapent
aussi wayne ans c'est horrible
les trois pièces mineurs contre la dame
c'est dure un mois le joueur français en
sur mon jeu largue
ouais il vient là
et c'est dur à je suis dans le dur la
ligne je suis mal juste assez dégueu
je chantais f4 pourrir le fou mais c'est
dégueu
c'est chaud là il a bien joué vous savez
à quel point ça me fait mal au coeur de
reconnaître ce genre de chose qu'est je
veux tenter tout reprend f4f 6 fou prend
dame ces trois fous des six tours des
huit fou c5 v6 le four par an à 3 et
peut-être une active
je vous prends ces deux est ce que c'est
vrai je pense que c'est là qu'il faut
essayer de faire un truc avec son fou et
je vais tenter f6 ça
attendait est-ce que je peux essayer le
foot le fourreau c7 peut être mal s'ils
avaient le temps de faire damas trois
tours sémites ce serait bien mais d'un
matériau bouger kheddam ces trois saints
paraît logique foule à tour des huit
foule a peut-être fou prend ces deux du
coup
ah il as intermédiaire à fallait faire
dame 3 en premier a je suis débile rage
me suis planté là je me suis planté là
voilà c'est fichu
dommage ten dam trois premiers tours des
huit mais j'étais mal quand même et je
voulais essayer du clac un fou ces deux
références en a plus jamais fait les
toasts au fromage
tu prends du pain tu mets tu mets du
fromage ecoplus dessus par mme de
l'emmental que ico plus donc pas un coup
plus et menthe à l'éco plus tu mets au
four et tu sors et a eu pas un fromage
très goûteux ça c'est une recette
intéressante on n'a pas fait depuis
longtemps
ok j'ai une position de merde maintenant
c'est mort quoi je suis sur damas six
pouces est à 4
un truc de donner trois pièces étaient
vraiment bien joué de sa part un feu
reconnaître mais j'arrive pas avoir de
jeu quoi c'est horrible vous ces sept
je suis complètement dominé là ça me
saoule
on peut rien faire quoi pas de contre
jeux à rien c'est attenter à 400 voix
sens bien que j'en vois quelque chose
hein
peut faire fou des cinq là elle sait
bien jouer il voit tout j'ai des petits
pièges mais les a vus on va prendre là à
faire 3 2 on va faire d'amd 5 pour
essayer de survivre sur ton français
devra d'ambea au moins tu es sur 17 sur
adam prend 17 pages essaye de survivre
si je réussis à thaksin russe a tapé à
envoyer mon pions passé pourrait avoir
une semi chance quoi j'aurais quand même
mal parce que jean patou quand j'aurai
être son pion mais mais les trois pièces
mineurs ils étaient fortes 1 contre la
dame sait bien jouer ça de nouveau il a
planqué luron h2c bien joué j'ai pas du
tout contre eux je en fait tu peux rien
faire je suis complètement dominé quoi
je peux pas taper à deux je peux rien
faire c'est quasiment abandonna bien
pour pas même pas l'ombre d'une idée
quoi
je peux même pas à créer une menace
c'est horrible mais dur à jouer ses
positions en rapide après on n'a pas
réfléchi très longtemps j'avais plus de
temps on a vraiment joué comme si c'est
un blitz est la maman c'est 5 sur échec
genre et b5 massaly dcb 5 des 4 b 3
toute façon le temps vous prendrez
coûter au moins c'est fini mais ouais
c'est dommage j'ai lévesque les trois
pièces en fait le premier coup la roja
chute c'était vraiment mal joué j'ai
raté qui est des cinq moment il fait
qu'il y ait des cinq après je suis très
très mal c'était si je commence par ces
six c'est ça va quoi mais j'ai fait un
très mauvais coup j'ai fait un très très
mauvais coup bon du coup un peu regardé
les autres partis en a peut-être
regarder arthur lucas tiens on attend un
critère qui a perdu 2 0 et s'amuser à
temps par contre on avait eu un automne
qui gagnent 2 0 on va regarder arthur
lucas tient faut que j'arrive les éval
parce que ça sert à rien on va se mettre
sur cette partie tranquillement de façon
lente à quoi on a longtemps la attendra
maintenant jusqu'au prochain match on a
l'habitude ya 37 minutes d'attentes là
on a on a le temps un merci à olivier
pour les 308
j'ai pressé le fm ça s'est fini en nul
n'est pas malin ils sont pas très fort
en nettement franchement là le fmi
compte qu'ils jouent était pas n'étaient
pas monstrueux qu'il a trouvé le beau
sacrifice de dames mais bon c'est pas
non plus là il n'a pas fait une super
partie connaissait très bien la théorie
par contre été super bien préparés
c'était quoi son blason en real juste
juste par nicolaï souvent sais pas qui
c'est quoi bizarre mais vers d'être bien
préparé dans la théorie qu il joue assez
vite les rives vraiment skis jouer ce
n'était pas mauvais j'imagine un bon
joueur je vais regarder s'il ya pas un
ce n'est bien dans tous les trucs mais
oui on va suivre va se faire déchirer
malheureusement parce qu'on est on est
on est pas si mauvais au final c'est
vraiment juste derrière ces deux risques
a glissé de partie des règles je compte
moins fort assez bizarre apprend-il
c'est vrai j'avais un copain de classe i
call après on a peut-être quatre points
qui vont nous revenir après 64 hazard ne
sais pas peut-être un point qui va en
venir
après c'est derrière moi et qu'on s'est
vraiment fait marcher dessus quoi mais
sinon devant c'était c'était chaud quoi
lorsque sa nature l'uqat a vérifié juste
du coup je vais vérifier c'est pas deux
lingway donc pro de chasse league jeudi
prochain ce sera un gros match aller
mais qu est-ce qu on peut se réinscrire
pour le prochain tournoi oui oui bien
sûr si tu quittes ce tournoi tu pourras
te réinscrire pour le pour le prochain
tournoi en fait sulky tard qu'ils soient
finis sera dans 35 minutes et donc
qu'est ce que je vous donne des
nouvelles de prod classique ça peut vous
intéresser
ouais donc l'équipe est plus ou moins et
plus ou moins fait un mais qui fait plus
ou moins fait j'ai l'impression que tous
les joueurs que j'ai mis peuvent jouer
je crois qu'il manque plus que les la
famille cornette mais bon ils étaient
ils étaient dix étaient ok donc non plus
que cette dernière confirmation entre
guillemets et ce sera bon pour jeudi
prochain
guillou 5 c'est de faire payer ses
caméras sur lui car et qui va mon avis
il a gagné une bonne position sur calais
detroit il va tout prendre en d3 et
y'aura dam des deux matches masquer ses
caractères se fout g6
donc il paraît quand même hymne de
driving site alors d'amener 3 c'est pas
mal ce qu'on pourrait penser que j'ai
six dames geste fou des trois échecs qui
menace la dame emma tanvez de marche
mais qui est prend des 3 donc c'est pas
mal tenté d donc cette affaire qu'il
prend g6 dame pranger si c'est quelque
chose d'autre genre fou ou huit dames
ces deux ouais c'est ça et fou g6 et ça
ça gagne s'il trouve ça ça il ya une
prise faut une huître ou g6 ça gagne
c'est sûr en projet a rencontré de
chasse bras ça pourrait bien ça en fait
on va faire une rencontre
[Musique]
hikaru wrench contre eux élevés à l'émoi
donc on va pas on va pas faire contre
lecce ce bras on va faire contrôler
contre lecce ce pied j'ai envie de dire
mais j'adore cette blague je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de la faire mais du coup on
va faire contre contre eux mais du coup
elle se fait piéger si ce machin ça va
gagner 10 dans le chat qui regardent le
live alors est platement mari je pense
pas qu'ils regardent attention si
regarde le mal le match est plié
c'est pas comme si ça allait souvent il
y avait 48 19 ne vous laisse pas comme
ça ait changé grand-chose qui gagne
cette partie ou pas ca sont là mon avis
on peut c'est on peut pas retourner le
score et 51,19 d'accueil si je me suis
fait laver mais bon elle est pas très
dur à trouver
je trouvais quasi tempo donc n'était pas
un méga compliqué salah a été plus que
trouvable cette tactique de bouffer
follow la chaîne chaise com/fr ainsi
s'est pas encore fait si c'est pas
encore le cas
n'hésitez pas à follow n'hésitez pas à
flots la chaîne assez intéressante que
du coup on n'est pas en première page on
va un peu combien il ya de il ya 2 il ya
deux personnes qui suivent sans les
premières pages donc c'est pas mal de
voir la différence est on est on est pas
on n'est pas on n'est pas on n'est pas
si mal on est dans les deux sens donc
c'est plutôt bien
ici sort pour retrouver le ton à
bärtschi monnet je vais remettre
prochain livre dans une petite demi
heure dans une petite débute pardon
j'arrive pas à une petite demi heure et
est fou g6 soyez à trouver mais c'était
pas très dur ça sentais qu'il y avait
quelque chose il devait y avoir quelque
chose
il devait forcément y avoir quelque
chose mais turquie merci callens du coup
ça t'a aidé voilà c'était pas volontaire
c'était pas volontaire mais bon c'est la
vie on est venu au bon moment du coup on
va essayer de rien dire sur la partie 2
et livia mais xenia qui est complètement
gagnant avec une pièce de plus donc ça
va aller mais en fait on aura remarqué
devant finalement devant on n'aura pas
face au maître fide écho plus au maître
fide écho plus on aura tenu maître fide
féminin au plus bien sûr il faut
s'entraider ouais enfin c'est là la
semaine dernière vendredi dernier arthur
tueur au niveau de l'entr'aide on a vu
mieux
il faut le savoir a l'embarras du choix
pour pour les noirs 1
moi j'aimais faire ici + 2 h 6 dans ses
positions l' histoire de fous là qu'est
ce qui se passe je comprends pas je
pourrai n'ont pas d'âme des 8,2 soit
sont taquins coup là donc t'as pas trop
à réfléchir après y'a pas de mattia rien
mais adam g sidam g2 qui arrive ça va
gagner tout seul
ah ok
ok j'ai compris sur d'alger si tu veux
faire tout rejet trois mois peut-être
faut juste changer un ordre de coûts
faire un truc quoi ça peut être je crois
pas une seconde ce truc là pour les
blancs
ouais
toi et fermière trouvait alors à prendre
un f6 dame f2 et ça va mater qui va
gagner ouais donc on en a on aura fait
des points devant mais c'est derrière
cessé sur le nombre quoi c'est après on
a un peu mal quoi on a peu de joueurs à
15 cents 16 cents et tout ça on se fait
dominer quoi au milieu devant on a bien
tenu coi mai mais derrière et fort notre
ami ukrainien à lui c'est sûr qu'ils
regardent pas le stream le gagnant et de
qualité de plus un hockey au pierre-yves
a largué une tour là mais le pion à ce
jeu va passer non mais du coup on a pas
mal on and on n'a pas mal joué on a bien
dominé quark cristal qui a perdu 2 0
contre 1900 s'étonnant ce étonnant
non
non on est pas mal
je viens pour pour les tournois il est
l'âne qui a tous les tournois 1 2 3 qui
est fait roi là pour éviter qu'à eux
deux échecs une fourchette de rival à
gagner ce qui est détruit peut-être
faire tourache cette tour eiffe cette
histoire 2 5pts f5 et plus sain parce
que tour à 7,3 des huit tours fc 3e 8
ans qui fait la justice
ah oui toi aussi juste âge s'ils
s'agissaient tg et six tours g8 oui bon
c'est tout aussi bien des tours g8
direct d'ailleurs évité collègues
wallace a gagné j'ai six tours g8 est le
cas il peut même paraître c'est
d'enlever tous gagnants non c'est
dommage que devant finalement contre les
gros et l'on n'aura tenu coi
on aura bien tenu devant et c'est
derrière que c'est la catastrophe allait
derrière donc on sait qui a perdu le
match dans le tchat
on sait qui a perdu le match
on sait à cause de qui on a perdu les
mecs sains j'ai pas envie de vous jeter
la pierre mais en fait je vous la jette
quand même quoi et j'ai envie de te dire
c'est pas de vent
j'ai envie de dire
vous m'avez déçu les mecs on veut des
noms on va tous les mecs qui ont perdu
2,01
je veux dire c'est simple tous les mecs
qui ont pris 2,01 null null quoi enfin
c'est à cause de vous que nous perdons
le match je pense à le charpentier
je pense à monsieur baisse closer je
pense à ce jeu s'appelle groot
je pense à sabre noir et je pense à the
bourbon kid tous a perdu 2,01 à tivat is
on se reconnaît on se reconnaît les gens
gros d'avs l'étape siens pacha risque
mais entre gens cisco jeff 85 ont l'âge
des blazes titouane gn cap et louis xii
bisons ont l'âge des blazes tous à la
voile à tous ces noms là que je viens de
lâcher tout ça c'est à cause d'eux est
un rôle moi j'ai fait un sur six est à
la fois mais c'est pas grave j'ai fait
un point là pour le mans 7 0 sur 2 je
lâche des blazes je lâche des blazes
tout ça ça à 0 sur 2 on verra bien j'ai
fait un sursis sont à gagner de match la
semaine dernière on verra si les gens
qui sont à zéro sur deux aujourd'hui on
en discutera est ce que dans une réunion
n'aura battu les russes
on verra on verra on en reparle
on en reparlera on avait gagné contre la
pologne
donc moi je suis responsable de rien le
match est gagné est ce qu'on aura gagné
ce soir on verra un qui pourra dormir et
se regarder devant 1 devant une glace
on ne sait pas
alors est ce que quelqu'un va réussir à
marquer
c'est pas évident il va peut-être perdre
g6 y avait 5 a beaucoup de pions qui
t'ont main
ce qu'il a réussi en réunion a peut-être
faire fous ces trois c'est d'envoyer
comme ça c'est chaud
j'ai peur de torah 5 la torah 5 tours b
si c'était tour prend 1,5 après tour
preuve 5 après moi peut-être fou ces
trois banques afin qu'ils fassent
pousser 3 et envoyer le pion se sent que
ça à faire mais bon c'est chaud l'aréna
ce soir ça à 21h mais comme tout les
arénas
comme tout les arenas à 21h comme tout
les ans à 21h et prochain soit dans
moins de deux minutes 56 me toi donc il
passe derrière ceinture et le prochain
tour a dû tout ça vaut quoi
ah ouais on est mal le prochain tournoi
on va se faire défoncer un mois je vais
déjà rejoindre aussi pour essayer de
repousser un peu les gens vers l'arrière
mais mais c'est dur
paris va être dur le prochain une
nouvelle fois ils ont trop de densité 1
ils ont trop de densité
ok il faut qu'il tente croire c63
bessette pour chasser la tour et qui
pousse le pion est bon peut-être il va à
l'arnaqué joue pas mal la finale que là
tant d un chant travail manina
cette foire jeu qui est mon
afr à 4 faire des trucs faut envoyer 1
sans voix sans voix
bref on voit les pions
ces foutues quand même mais bon
peut-être un peu arnaquer
on peut aussi commencer par tours b 1
mais je l'aurais pas fait mais il peut
le faire mais accueilli ces cinq échecs
maintenant je raconte des conneries tour
berne accueille ces cinq échecs
lorsqu'ils envoient le pion dans à 3 de
toute façon tour bien qu'ils essaient
cinq échecs
non ça ça me plaît pas du tout faut
qu'il fasse à 3 ouais ils sont deux fois
plus que nous après vu le nombre de
russes qui joue aux échecs et de et le
nombre de français qui jouent aux échecs
c'est plutôt bien pour nous
peut-être simplement deux fois moins
honnêtement on est plutôt beaucoup en
réalité si tu compares en nombre dans
nombre de gens qu'on pourrait
théoriquement être et le nombre de gens
qu'on essaie plutôt bien mais bon
problème c'est qu'ils ont beaucoup plus
de joueurs à 15 sans quoi ils ont
beaucoup plus de joueurs moyens que nous
on fait un double poney qui jouera
contre ludmila attention il ya beaucoup
de filles aussi un attention très
intéressant pour pécho en fait ça c'est
vrai qu'on arrive dans la vie de compris
en fait nous
mais ils sont très nombreux surtout que
les russophones futur ajoute aussi les
dpi qui joue beaucoup aux effets à baa3
est accueilli ces cinq échecs à trois
essais cinq échecs aussi en fait j'ai
complètement fou
bon je voyais jouer à jouer à plusieurs
en fait je vois pas trop aurait en fait
il ya ça aussi
non mais ça marchait pas du tout façon
le truc qui avait foulé 4 mai même on
sait tout de suite mort ça il ya au pire
les cavaliers prend et tour protégés et
les pions vont parler dit mais la tour
en b2 et puis fait le k3 f4 machin est
plus qu autour des 3 aussi jouable tour
du 3 peut-être pas malheur bon
c'est qu'il n'y a dans le docu âge là je
passe sa fille contre qui tu joues un
port en tapant feinte été appariés à
l'instant conclut 2001 après j'suis pas
qu'on ne sait pas si ça a changé non
maintenance et féline force qui jouent
contre adolia dimitri dommage tu jouais
contre ludmila 86 toi je peux t'offrir
la page à l'écran tu jouer contre elle
on voit pas bien si on voit bien par
contre la faute aux pâtes et riz mais tu
jouer contre elle et puis finalement
pschitt allemands ils l'ont enlevée quoi
la place à dimitri est le charbon ticc y
en a marre de jeu quand des mecs qui ont
400 euros de plus ouais mais bon c'est
notre quotidien
il trouve un peu de contre quand même
il trouve un peu de jeu pile
il va ramener le roi et j'aurais plutôt
mis la tour derrière le pion mais bon il
va essayer de ramener le roi et ouais il
se bat bien il joue pas mal que l'un je
trouve
même s'il ya sûrement perdre il se sera
battue à fond - faut vraiment qu'il faut
pas qu'ils aillent par là bas avec le
roi je pense il faut essayer de revenir
par ici
dont g2j crois pas trop hein je pensais
faire roi des six mon corps et pendant
l'été c'est un coup un truc c'est que la
trouve pas aussi bouger maintenant
kg 4,9 à partir ça va être ça et dure un
an nous demanderons à b4 3b trois tours
bien ce qu'il va faire tout reprendre à
deux et puis tu arrêteras pas les pions
un cyril donc non nous sont les forts et
l'eau français je sais pas où ils sont
justement c'est un peu ça le problème
c'est un peu ça le problème c'est que je
sais pas où ils sont
félin ferrand s'est dit désolé mec si
mal c'est moi avec ludmila dans le monte
la laisse en fait franchement on a vu
les photos
franchement vu les photos félin féroce
alors à qui repasse vers 5 c'est
horrible il ya trop de piau il ya trop
de pions
après voiture à des systèmes graphiques
et ce qu'il faut qu'il aille en g7 où on
set dj set c'était peut-être intéressant
aussi c'est vrai que si il peut être
pour ça que vidéo c'est peut-être
intéressant parce que s'il récupère les
deux pions amis vous êtes faire 3 5
tours prend à deux trois projets si
c'est la tour b tour j'ai deux arrêtes
ton g2 ça à faire mal
à
ouais c'est dégueu
c'est dégueu dont g de roissy s'ouvrait
vii est vrai de toute façon la torah pas
le temps de passer de l'autre côté fo
qui tente un truc comme ça mais il est
trop tard dommage il s'est bien battu
il s'est bien battu
seule la l'option passé tu peux rien
faire malheureusement
on est quand même assez nombreux ouais
devant on n'est pas si mal mal quand on
peut s'accrocher c'est vraiment derrière
notre problème n'est pas se prendre un
ponte du sénat si son adversaire sait le
faire trucs pas mal cessé de mettre la
tour sur la 4e peut-être pour essayer de
brouiller les pistes
jean retour f4
l'autre connaît malheureusement
bref cette tour f 3 3 6 tours trois rois
f6 et là le meilleur piège c'est tenter
à y mêler peut pas le faire parce qu'ils
les dernières colonnes tour f-35 et ses
morts et surtour un tour j'ai 5 tours 5
alpha mos au pont de l'ue scénar est
annoncé mort 1
ça inquiète ou re5 et c'est fini accueil
qui va devoir s'incliner
je vais faire tout reif 8 ici là il
aurait pu faire tout est fluide pour
tenter le parent est effectivement pas
quand le roi était en peut-être avec un
truc un peu plat c'est un peu
différemment
il reste 10 minutes en prochain match on
va rester en toute détente les mecs on
va pas se passe sur excitant à voir
comment on va voir qui je vais mettre je
vais être un peu à l'écran les matches
d'après ce que j'ai compris c'est pas le
score total qui compte c'est le nombre
de matches gagnés mais on n'a aucune
chance quoi on n'est pas assez fort
c'est parce qu'il a récupéré ludmila
bien joué et bien joué donc ph
parce qu'à récupérer
ludmila mais qu'il a reperdu combat par
félin force quoi paraissent deux minutes
allaient faut essayer de se battre on
n'est pas si peu que ça au final ta
l'auto promotion 15,8 ouais ouais je
l'auto promotion parce qu'en fait je
peux pas faire autopromotions tu fait
halte voilà on peut pas jouer un coup
pour l'eau tu fait halte et puis t'as
plus l'auto promotion en fait quand tu
connais l femmes aux raccourcis clavier
c'est facile ça fait vraiment isréliens
qui chassent points comme ça des matches
plus équitable à la semaine dernière
contre la pologne c'était équitable on a
gagné on a gagné à l'arraché 1 contre
les polonais de la semaine prochaine
contre les turcs aussi mais bon les
russes c'est vrai que les russes et
espagnols ils sont beaucoup plus
nombreux donc c'est dur donc oui comme
je connais les raccourcis clavier
je laisse l'auto promotion halte et
promotions ingénierie mais bon il faut
connaître un il faut connaître et un peu
ce qu'on écrit sur les commentaires de
la prod chez ces gens sont heureux en
othe réducteur propre châssis
j'ai l'impression que tu approches
classiques c'est un peu comme les
saisons précédentes c'est qu'en début de
saison en fait la vraie personne qui
suit vraiment et puis plus les matchs
avant ce pull est plus les gens
plus la saison avançait de plus les gens
sont chauds et c est ce que c'est toutes
les saisons pareil
et ça c'est cool c'est moi en fait que
que tous les que que tous les ans ce
soit le même soit le même truc en fait
demande c'est quoi ton vélo - lo fi de
2003 quelque chose près archi médias à
75 mais les mecs on s'inscrit à fond m
on est beaucoup moins vrai renée
beaucoup - ipsos et au milieu c'est
vraiment milieu quoi c'est la quantité
de joueurs au milieu qui fait vraiment
la différence en poche approcha si
c'était un coup de génie de chasse comme
ray c'est sympa parce que je trime
essentiellement les échecs juste rim que
des échecs way
malheureusement ou heureusement mais je
stream que des échecs
et là c'est pas ma chaîne perso c'est
une chaîne il ya vraiment que des échecs
du coup ni wayne dans cette pro che
slick ça s'apprend s'apprend sur le tard
et c'est plutôt cool de voir que les
gens finissent pas raccroché elle serait
qu on m'écrit bientôt les vendent bien
tôt les vernis la bonne et les mecs
empêche un sur la chaîne youtube on est
à combien on est à 10,9 1928 ouais ça va
arriver d'ici une semaine je vais faire
une soirée spéciale le combien j'avais
dit le 23 samedi 23 j'allais me faire un
p'tit truc un petit meetup avec les
abonnés sur cannes
s'il ya des gens j'en reparlerai
je pense que je vais me chauffer
mais ça et qu'on sait bien proche et 6
avec sais pas je suis content que ça
commence à prendre la voix magique
kotick bientôt porte drapeau des jeux à
paris ré mais tu sais moi je suis plutôt
je suis pas pour un ce truc d échec aux
jo personnellement mais bon je vois que
tout le monde et pour donc je comprends
que mon avis est très minoritaire mais
mais pour moi les échecs sont pas un
sport et pour moi faire deux heures
d'échec ça équivaut pas faire une km de
course à pied mais après je sais pas
c'est sûrement moi vu que tout le monde
pense que c'est normal d'écrire ce genre
de choses sur ans - qui comprend papa du
coup aujourd'hui c'est vrai que je vais
faire six heures et demie de stream ça
fait 8 16
en plus sans stream ans ça me fait
peut-être 30 km de course à pied quoi
plus d'un s'échauffent
j'ai une grosse condition physique ce
match que ça se ressente pas le samedi
matin quand je joue au tennis
tous ces efforts tous ces kilomètres
parcourus est ce qu'on me dit tu vois
que ses équivalents jolie j'arrive au
tennis tu veux je peux quand même courir
je peux quand même faire des marathons
tous les jours faire donc je me dis bon
je suis bien mais en fait non il
commence donc maintenant le prochain
match dans quatre minutes d'ailleurs les
mecs faut se bouger je vous remets les
liens faut se bouger pour s'inscrire
wiseid court trop après ouais après je
suis beaucoup d' escalade s'il faut le
savoir sans qat une va se faire défoncer
on va les défendre mais dylan mais
devant on peut le faire un franchement
c'est plus sur la densité qu'on se fait
battre mais devant on peut on peut on
peut on peut sortir le match quoi mais
c'est après que c'est dur et je vous en
veux pas les mecs sains vous je compte
plus fort que vous mêmes et ils ont plus
de 1600 1800 que nous après les 1000 on
en a on en a à foison quoi ouais j'ai vu
les 60 millions d'audience en chine
mais bon tu sais le plongeon synchronisé
fait autant d'audience 1 en fait tard
hall est en fait si tu mets le truc sur
tf1 à 20h30 avec un armageddon aura
aussi en france 2 millions d'audience en
fait faut le savoir
en fait c'est hyperimportant la chaîne
du coup c'est sur la chaîne sportive
numéro un ils ont dû faire beaucoup de
pub et il ya eu du monde mais ça change
rien
ce qui est important c'est de voir si
dans la russie dans les journaux et tout
ça ça parle d'échec ou quoi c'est
surtout ça qu'il faut voir
qui vaut formation de vitrines donc
beaucoup demi le lot assez gentil à la
tat kpk mais je me fais troll par le
chat c'est incroyable quand on peut
rejoindre le tour magique aux tic faut
que tu te dépêches te met les liens
comme ça tu as tout le tattoo le truc
j'ai fait un truc tout explicatifs pour
que les gens comprennent mais en terme
de nombre on est on est pas franchement
n'est pas si loin à prendre franchement
c'est super si tu compare le nombre de
gens le nombre potentiel de russes qui
jouer et le nombre de joueurs qu'on a
franchement on n'est pas si mal
c'est le retour du karma kevin en
méthane tuapati mettre aussi non mais
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable mais
je le mérite mais pourquoi du mérite
pourquoi je l'aï c'est incroyable je
suis votre souffre douleur attention les
gens il faut combien de temps pour
atteindre 1700 je suis 1250 ça dépend
comment tu travailles du stack et ça
dépend avec qui tu prends des cours on
ne sait pas moi j'ai plus de place mais
les profs c'est plus qualitative de
attention c'est pas bon je rigole mais
non mais ça dépend combien tu travailles
quel est ton talent enfin y'a pas de
jean ans après avec la fédé qui est plus
importante que celle de foot je
comprends vraiment pas pourquoi ça ne
parle pas d'échec dans la rue ouais en
fait les deux tel sportif parole non
mais c'est hallucinant en fait mais je
pense qu'avoir une honnêtement je pense
qu'avoir une tuque regret sur blistering
point fr tu peux regarder supergen au
master class archi médias et on va
préparer des vidéos payantes aussi par
la suite mais en fait je pense qu'avoir
une communication juste d'être d'accord
avec par rapport à ce que dit harold ou
quoi ou par rapport à ce que je rigolais
avec les deux heures égal à égal lui km
de course je pense qu'avoir une course à
pied je pense qu'avoir une communication
aussi délirante avec des arguments aussi
délirant je pense que c'est
contreproductif en fait pendant le
marketing ou quoi quand ils vendent des
trucs qui mentent mais un petit peu tu
vois on de on it on te vend pas on ne
vend pas le fromage écho plus pour pour
pour le fromage le plus le plus le plus
goûteux du monde
artisanat le machin tu vois je pense à
c'est contre-productif quand on rajoute
pas un peu mais quand on ajoute des méga
super todd lors il ya plus de joueurs
d'échecs que de joueurs de foot ok
il ya bien le curling audio c'est pas
super physique pourquoi pas les échecs
la différence c'est que le curling ça
demande une pas une aptitude physique
mais le coeur l'ignorent attendez on va
fermer ça pour être bien cadrer le corps
le curling c'est un peu du fer ou quatre
pour changer le curling ça demande une
une agilité en fait sa demande de
l'agilité donc c'est qu'elle parraine
une compétence physique que les échecs
ne demande pas forcément mais bon les
échecs au physique au les échecs aux jo
d'hiver se serait pas si délirant que ça
dans un sens mais pas aux jo d'été
mais bon ça fait un petit peu réfléchir
pour le pour le comprendre mais les
échecs pourrait être un sport de divers
plus que d'été en fait donc on va faire
dam des deux crocs
déjà s'il ya moins de sport dont les jo
d'hiver
donc c'est un avantage et deuxièmement
c'est plus un truc d'intérieur les
échecs
donc si on réfléchit bien ça pourrait
plus marcher dans ce sens là bon alors
on va y aller gaiement
on voyage 4,6 foule 3
ouais éventuellement mixé avec un autre
sport loach est comme le chessboxing par
exemple ok on va mettre le front des 5
pour la position est pas clair du tout
c'est très compliqué f 4 kg et 4 dames
eux deux avec l'idée peut-être de faire
f 5 et sur cavaliers ceccacci peut-être
dames 2 quand même quel genre de truc
que j'ai pas mal analysé en fait pas
cette position exactement mais ce genre
de schéma
après je joue vite donc je sais pas si
je joue bien c'est genre de truc sur
lequel j'ai pu passer du temps à
analyser et bien khalef 5 intermédiaire
faire j'ai quatre c6 ramener le fou
après j'ai cinq tenniche est ça existe
ouest et laurent frayssinet le champion
du monde de tennis sheth avoir reculé on
va revenir en iran des quatre fers b3
ouais normalement on attaquait les plus
rapides que la sienne parce que je veux
quand même j'ai cinq tours j'ai un tout
cas je vous plus vite que lui ce qui est
un peu con mais ce qui est drôle donc
est bon il veut changer les cavaliers
pourquoi pas écouté je suis pas sûr que
ce soit si grave d'échanger sa page et
rauque et dans un sens il se dit qu'ils
me fais un truc mais je faire pour g1 et
g6 peut-être l'un je pense qu on prend
ça peut-être sa meilleure chance
pratique équidés de reprendre là
que je continue à jouer vis tu m'en fous
j'en vois je suis très heureux du coup
mais le problème c'est que j'aurai pas
d'un match 5 ans je me suis fait avoir
comme une merde jouer trop vite au nom
s'en était rendu compte 1 je vois pas ce
qu'on fait sur g6 prise prise j'ai plus
j'ai pu d'un match 5 à cause de la tour
je me suis enflammé à jouer vitoria une
position complètement gagnante et
j'aurais pas dû
j'aurais pas dû faire ça moi je vais
faire tout rejet trois tours j'ai un
mois j'ai cette case là peut-être que je
cours je vais peut-être essayer de faire
quelque chose mais je sais pas quoi
je me suis un peu précipité j'avais une
fourchette tour dames
ouais c'est possible je regarde je suis
pas méga concentré j'avais une
fourchette tour dames
honnêtement je ne vois pas quel moment
mais j'ai peut-être quelque chose ne
fait qu'aider 5 je pensais que c'est un
bon coup je continue à jouer vite et mal
absolu tous les choix c'est que je
couvre un peu cette case aussi c'était
un site et dans l'idée ça
j'ai peut-être gsi ceux ci qui apparaît
comme coûts prises prise fou issifou c4
j'aurais peut-être dû regarder ça aussi
alors pions prend dame prend tout
reprend roi ici c'est très chiant
sur tanger dedans des deux rois des deux
n'a pas d'âge ahmed hammache 5 c'est un
problème ça
parce que puis on prend prise prix g7 au
même cera endroit je suit en fait tout
point f7 tmb de roi des deux baies 3
j'attends que ça pue si je laisse
prendre le cavalier mais je vois pas
comment faire autre chose on va aller on
va essayer t'es sûr et j'ai raté un truc
qu'il prend
ce que ces trois intermédiaires c'est
une idée
est d'alger 2
cavalli 3 noeuds ça dans les c3 qui
répond au projet 16 dames g4 qu'elle
prend à deux voix ces deux dames d2
machin je pense je fais maths et à
six-fours pranger cette bouche machin il
manque un coût financé horrible
saddam g can am by de roide et 2 1 3 2 3
ou année 1
il ya toujours il prend toujours un f5
annoncé mort
c'est mort de partout en fait à un temps
près pas je me serai plus concentré sa
là j'aurais gagné deux parties bon j'ai
joué trop vite
j'ai joué trop vite c'est dommage je
suis apprécié ont été gagnantes mais
j'ai pensé que c'était plus simple que
ça a gagné du coup je t'en ai tenté
d'amener de roi des deux trois rois des
trois c'est peut-être ma meilleure
chance tous les autres coupeurs sauf
peut-être ça vous vois pas de gain
direct mais le truc qui m'inquiète c'est
bon après j'ai une menace the last
hurrah cette dame je m'assure à cette
dame g7 ont peut-être trois des deux
rois machin ça tiens je sais pas c'est
le seul truc qui peut tenir en tout cas
bon j'ai une menace ce que dame g2 en
fait ça permet avec les cavaliers f4 qui
arrive est donc d'amener 4 avec l'euro
en d3 c'est la seule chance
on est prêt à faire hills ou s'il fait
une connerie en tout cas la position est
marrante
ilisu et ix où dit il il y sous ilisu
ilisu bien ça c'est comme faire de
qualité là vous avez des deux rois des
deux forcenés qui a eu trois échecs que
trois rois des trois forces est ok aussi
des trucs à québec quatre pour dévier la
dame et où il ya tout un tas trucs
possibles
je fais un truc comme genre cavaliers b4
et tour des cinq échecs ça me paraît
super fort il fait dame ces trois rois
eux deux à oui hélas yade hamdami sid
ahmed hammache ahmat ok ok c'était sûr
qu'il va maintenant j'ai déconné
bêtement vraiment j'aurais pu la gagner
ça là désolé les mecs même on est mené
43 à 3 donc offert en fait c'est ça le
truc c'est qu'il ya aucun enjeu coiffard
on s'en fout totalement quoi c'est
dommage qu'on aurait pu faire mieux pas
j'aurais pu faire mieux
ah ça me soulage et en bijoux un truc
bizarre ça me saoule un an mes salades
dans une arena ont croce si vous dans un
truc un peu plus je fais un peu plus
attention je pense que je la gagne la
précédente même quasiment sûr mais bon
là et 46 à 3 c abusé quoi
tu comprends pas pourquoi je comprends
pas en quoi ce format ici génial parce
que je veux dire moi j'ai fait un retour
là dessus en disant que qu'il fallait
changer quelque chose que le format
était pas top c'était peut-être un poil
moi je dis quoi je disais que c'était un
poêlon hewitt les matches étaient pas
trop équilibré on m'a dit que tous les
autres tous les to toutes les autres
communautés tous les autres pays sont
contents après je sais pas pas
l'impression que j'ai un nez russes ont
quand même pas très nombreux par rapport
à un communiqué en terme de population
de joueurs d'échecs ces îles sont ils
n'aiment pas deux fois plus que nous
donc je pense pas que ce soit si heureux
que ça mais bon je voulais raccourcir
les quatre ans on m'a dit tu es plutôt
les peut-être même les rallonger donc à
bon je sais pas j'aime ce que je suis
complètement à l'opposé de du reste du
monde
voir c'est être con comme visite est ce
qu on est plus nombreux que du coup on a
peut-être une qualité plus grande en en
comparaison du nombre de gens qui jouent
et c'est donc on est plus large on n'a
plus envie de s'amuser quoi donc je sais
pas mais mais c'est un peu tourner ce qu
ils vont la c-zéro pas bons sont pas
deux fois plus que nous il ya peut-être
20 portant plus de joie russe que nous
donc je sais pas trop mais bon là ouais
on se fait trop défoncé quoi on se prend
57 à 4 rebonds cf
c'est dur quoi
ma position je propose est nul en fait
du coup pour aller un peu voir ce que
vous faites
parce que ça pas forcément la précédente
c'est dommage de ne pas avoir gagné
quand même mais bon après est bénéfique
aux tic je l'aï battu un joueur qui est
ici 100 points de plus maintenant il
veut la jouer quoi il ya déjà dix points
d'écart et à 40 points d'écart et les
mecs vous quand même la jouer quoi fin
pourquoi en fait je crois pas je ne
comprends pas tu parles comme ils ont
déjà gagné je me dit mon vieil ami ok en
fait on fait nul et pions c'est étrange
quelque chose que je que qui me qui me
dépasse il ya des choses qui me
dépassent les gens peut-être que prendre
de se prendre un pis ou quoi
les dauphins ils pourront jouer a été
mauvais esprit va je sais pas on a déjà
perdu donc fin je sais pas vous avez
déjà gagné vous avez déjà gagné quoi je
suis mauvais esprit fait très attention
je sais pas moi je dis tu as gagné tu as
gagné enfin genre bravo
ok c'est pas mal joué on va prendre
prendre
ok bon
le plaisir de jeu au delà du résultat
mais je suis arrivé vous êtes bizarre
peut-être pour moi juste quand tu as
gagné tu as gagné enfin je sais pas si
tu fais un match c'est pour rien sur le
pour t'amuser tu fais un truc pour
t'amuser quoi bon alors
on peut essayer de faire un truc marrant
mais je crois pas que ça fonctionne il
aurait essayé
enfin
dommage il a vu un il a vu ce que je
voulais tenter
dommage c'était joli ce que je voulais
essayer de combiner mais on va pas y
arriver et mec
j'ai voulu faire le beau jeu j'ai vu que
ça marchait pas mais j'ai eu un espoir
fou qui se plante mais il se plante pas
du coup le beau jeu j'essaie de faire un
truc avec damas je crois qu'ils aient g4
qui vint matin un math forcé mais le
problème c'est que le four revient au
bon moment quoi malheureusement pour
vous expliquer ce que je voulais essayer
de tenter je vais faire un truc jolie où
tu donnes du matériel me tu finis le roi
là bas dans le coin ce qui aurait pu
être marrant
mais ce qui n'a pas marché je pensais
peut-être sur dame c s est fait un truc
avec tours ces huit dames prendre froid
mais en fait j'ai pas le temps de faire
d'un match moi je suis obligée de
commencer par kg katia le temps de faire
h 4 au pire à la suite être faire g5 à
ce moment là ray mais ça marche jamais
ces trucs là sa marge à mais honnêtement
ça marche jamais ces trucs là dommage
parce que si ça marche et ça pourrait
être marrant mais ça va pas fonctionner
dommage
enfin il fait h4 bon
est ce que je peux faire dame c'est 500
est il à s'attaquer gesa attaquer donc
si je fais dame c5
j'attaque ça je défends sa [ __ ] j'ai
raté cette tactique à la con qu'est-ce
que je suis compétent a cité damas un
que ça gagner tout de suite ces dames à
5 le coup qu'est-ce que je suis débile
c'était damas cinq c'était fini tout
dans les têtes tour au match a encore
mesdames à cinq je pense que ça gagne
par à la dame à 500 a gagné et surtour
ces trois dames français 3d qu'elle
prend à eux deux qui est pro f 4
qu'est-ce que je suis des villages pas
assez concentré je suis pas assez
concentré
arrive pas à jouer sans motivation c'est
grave c'est grave
fa c'est normal en fait mais c'est
chiant quand même dès que je suis pas
motivé je fais des erreurs comme ça là
conquois au monde conclure c'est relou
telle est ma nature
telle est ma nature presse je suis
mauvais esprit je me rappelle mauvais
esprit
alors
euh bon
durant cette position et à la ferme
tellement con de ma part aussi des bons
par rapport à bien jouer dans l'arène à
tout à l'heure
camatte a tancé 6 à mes affaires qui
essaient 4
après je peux rien faire c'est horrible
la finale est vraiment horrible
c'est vraiment dur cette finale est
vraiment injouable il ya le pion qui
arrivant et l'option de plus en fait
t'es trop fort ici oui c'est sûr que
dans l'arena le mec a aucune chance mais
avec l'enjeu c'est sûr que je le défonce
mais sans enjeu du rhin
non en fait je peux jouer sans enjeu
mais si c'est pas un tournoi
en fait s'il n'y a pas d'enjeu je peux
jouer sans l'enjeu mais en fait quand il
ya un petit ange au début et que l'on se
fait défoncer là c'est juste que
j'arrive plus du tout quoi faut vraiment
qu'ils aient pas d'enjeu de base quoi du
coup il n'y a pas du tout dans le jeu de
base que je joue dans l'esprit de
m'amuser ou quoi de base ça va m'aider
qui est un peu dangereux c'est vrai que
je n'arrive pas du tout à ça le truc
c'est que je considère pas ça comme est
quand même je considère pas ça comme
étant un défaut en fait je considère ça
comme étant normal 6 ce qui est un
deuxième problème en fait
mais là il ya tour ici il va revenir
avec le cavalier en s'écartant juste qui
est frustrant ce qui m'est tellement de
temps pour gagner ce truc là tu ailles
galères tellement pour la gagne et que
tu te dis d'autant plus chiant de la
perdre quoi
chants de la perdre qui à l'air autant à
la gagner
à 4 comprend ck3 ici on va jamais dames
et donc on est obligés de faire le tour
avec le roi ou jouer pour le pion à
ouais c'est horrible
ouais c'est mort ouais c'est dommage
dommage d'avoir fait dame c52 pas avoir
fait gaffe de ne pas avoir calculé c'est
con c'est comme ça va faire partie était
belle mais le reste des comptes dès
qu'on était mal en fait c'était fini
pour moi quoi sa chance et c'est de
faire ça m laurent à 3 et essayer de
pousser droit jusqu'à un mètre le pion à
dos et faire un pat
normalement il va le voir m
kasso gens ce qu'ils fassent 3,17 à 2 c
8 et prendre mais ça reste quand même
foutu
ça reste quand même foutu à cause de ça
c'était pas loin de l'arnaqué 1
les mecs honnêtement s'arrêter en cas où
on l'aurait battue franchement si je
n'aurais pas eu les trois secondes de
parcous n'y aurait pas eu les trois
secondes par coup lors arnaque est quand
même un fils qui était messieurs
seraient fric
bon allez c'est pas grave on s'en fout
complètement mais dommage mais je pense
d'un mass index a gagné bêtement dans
les deux parties des trucs pour gagner
je pense damas 500 gagne juste direct en
fait tu mets à ce drame france et trois
à mens tu as dame français 3,25 steffi
immédiatement je suis tellement bête
c'était tellement simple en plus à voir
c'est vraiment abandonné automatique
permet du coup ces dames e3 seul coup je
pense hélas il ya cavaliers ces deux
gagne tout de suite et joua pas du tout
comment ils défense
j'ai pas si je peux être l'ordi pour
analyser mais d'un bassin qui fait sa
fin je suis sûr que ça gagne tout de
suite c'était vraiment va être de faire
la c5 je suis tombé dans le seul piège
j'aurais dû réfléchir plus longtemps
bien physiquement même temps faire ça et
j'ai pas j'ai pas vu pas réfléchi
longtemps offert d'amasser 5000 24
secondes il joue alger par lg pas
vraiment regardé ce qu'il pouvait faire
dommage mais madame à 500 a regagné
clean
non mais bon on fait un vrai truc c'est
qu'on se fait trop défoncé quoi il ya
trop d'écarts il ya trop d'écarts
bon allez il reste le bullet pour se
refaire et sur dames sanya tout reprend
ses huit armes et sa grille direct enfin
c'est complètement débile par mach 4
c'est hallucinant fait comme pousse et
ça ça ne pouvait pas être bon comme quoi
c'était vraiment forcément très mauvais
mais je sais pas pourquoi j'ai pas une
fin ouais non mais je sais projet pas vu
pas à pas concentré du coup et je me
prends un truc ridicule
ouais ils sont trop forts pour nous
est-ce que c'est mathématiquement mort
frais c'est la peine dont deux têtes les
bâtons bull est allé on peut peut-être 1
m et non mais on est trop faible
derrière de nouveau on est trop faible
derrière on n'y peut rien les mecs on
est trop faible
non mais pu essayer de gagner un mini
match mais le truc c'est qu'on est on
n'a aucune chance
on n'a aucune chance ou alors faut que
tous les mecs avec des petits lots se
désinscrivent mais bon mais on n'a
aucune chance les mecs n'ont se fait
défoncer bon mais la bonne nouvelle
c'est que la semaine prochaine c'est le
dernier match contre les turcophones et
du coup on aura de nouveau une chance
ouais on aura une chance à semaine
prochaine on a mené quelques minutes au
début au début on était bien
pourquoi faut-il hausse et 2000 devrait
pas faut qu'on essaye de se battre quand
même de faire quelque chose je sais pas
on se fait trop défoncé quoi c'est abusé
franchement mais moi ça me choque mais
voit le premier c'est normal je m' a mal
joué je pense est normal que vous
mettiez a mal joué aussi c'est dur après
temps quand on se fait défoncer comme ça
c'est dur de bien jouer c'est normal les
mecs c'est normal que vous ayez du mal
c'est foutu tu te fais trop enchaîné je
fais 3 enchaînés et arrivent plus à ça
on a du mal à relever la tête quand on
fait un match perdu
[Musique]
on avait connu un peu la même chose en
pro-chasse lic s'écoule du coup pour la
protéger c'est qu'ils aient changé le
classement où les points que tu marques
qui compte au classement
du coup tu es tu as tu réussi quand même
à dire qu'il faut il faut faire quelque
chose
mais là c'est dur je vais peut-être
tenté une robe quand même je vais
peut-être tenté une robe et ce soir dans
l'arena rarement uricaru sera cool après
je sais pas à quel point on pourra
lutter pour les premières places semaine
dernière j'ai super bien joué cette
semaine cette semaine on verra après des
fois il ya un peu le coc comment dire là
les vaches cherche moment les
circonstances des fois tu as une partie
qui se passe d'une partie qui se passe
mal tu peux avoir des circonstances
positives ou négatives
j'espère en faire partie se passe bien
mais c'est une grob la gros beauf honni
là on est vraiment dure
honnêtement je marque beaucoup plus
quand on fait deux tournois entre nous
même c'est pour les commenter ou pour
les jouets ou toi je trouve que c'est
beaucoup plus galerie que se faire
défoncer quoi même quand on a rien
contre les polonais à la semaine
dernière franchement bon sais pas
peut-être n'est pas ces tests quand il
conçoit plus nombreux ou qu'on puisse
être prêt contre j'attends le truc tepa
ajaccio quand on joue la prod chez slick
par exemple on a vraiment l'impression
qu'il se passe quelque chose
tiens je comprends où on va je comprend
ce qu'on fait tout ça il faudrait
peut-être faut deux fois et peut-être
ferait peut-être plus sur le sur le live
en fait ça peut être une idée ça
peut-être pour pour pour les prochains
d'être plus sur le live à discuter à un
machin éventuellement c'était une idée
la russe qui répondent le fait qu'on
sera nul c'est le problème des français
louis monde on a quand même gagné la
coupe du monde de foot chez eux quoi du
coup j'ai envie de te dire j'ai envie de
te dire qu'on est content quand tu perds
contre quand tu te fait bon manger la
coupe du monde de foot chez toi genre il
te dira nous l'organisons 98 pour la
gagner tu vois palmarès de la rue si
j'avais été le champion du monde de
football au bout d'un moment c'est calme
le sport ultime le foot j'ai fait quoi
j'ai dû en effet faire un sur trois pour
le moment où ans sur quatre même dommage
que je pourrais avoir facile 3 sur 4
mais bon c'est la vie
allons essayer le dernier la dernière
l'heure d'arrivée à 21h
mais oui donc attend faut faut les
calmer quand même ils n'ont pas gagné
leur coupe du monde allait grob aller là
grob et un état d'esprit
l'hymne des quatre à aller on la joue à
la 11 km 3 mamans c'est chaud bon allez
au moins je m'amuse là c'est chaud c'est
un contrat maître fide faut vraiment lui
il faut vraiment le battre quoi bon je
suis sur tous les fronts finance cette
drogue ne semble pas trop mal se passer
coûte et j'ai réussi à développer mes
pièces ce qui est souvent des problèmes
de lag robe je deviens un des problèmes
parce que groupe connais plein de
problèmes mais on est bien on est pas
mal à faire h3 on va essayer d'ouvrir le
jeu la colonne h
je pense que doit jouer g3 ici c'est
vers ce qui fait
et plusieurs écoles mais j'ai envie de
faire l'école la plus bourrine f4 je
vais essayer de récupérer son pion après
en douceur est allé le maté en force sur
les pubs par le pion g3 on sera vraiment
bien parce qu'apprendre à la colonne
ouverte et on enchaînera mais peut-être
pas si simple à capturer puis ont géré
cette affair tour g1 des reflets f3
puisque le fou sera mieux en f3 et
n'empêchera cai h5 vocale et givat la
boîte zf 6 âgées qu'on s'en fout rien à
[ __ ]
alors
comment est ce qu'on peut faire de la
violence puis en tête ont fait un petit
échec pour commencer
ok
maintenant j'en ai dû faire f 5
j'ai l'impression qu'on a mis son roi
dont le dans le corner face même pas une
impression nam il saura dans le corner
et faut aller le finir j'ai quasiment
vide faire flouer 4 que j'ai eues en
caisse c'est un pion qu'elle ait envie
lui encaissé parce que c'est toujours un
pion de plus un au caire
j'ai envie de faire le beau jeu bien
évidemment le bon je vous demande de
jouer de la merde
le beau jeu requiert de jouer ça je suis
pas sûr que ça passe mais mais c'est le
beau jeu le beau jeu requiert sa et en
tant qu'apôtre du beau jeu nous avons
une obligation
ok
hélas devenir complètement étonnante une
affaire d'âme france et 3 comme ça je
vais freiner son attaque et je vais
préparer d'un projet 3 pour ramener la
dame
ce qui est somme toute assez logique en
réalité
oui mesdames ranger 3 par match en 1 ou
en deux fins en deux je veux dire
qu'est-ce que je rate je rate rien
tonton boum boum boum lui on l'a tapée à
les lags robe talent et manon borg et
maintenant la borg
allez on va essayer dû placer les deux
on va essayer de le grauby fier on va
essayer de le grauby fier une robe et
une borg
ce serait beau quand même
allez on y va on y va les mecs avec le
fonds 17
bon finalement ça va à la position
honnêtement j'ai vu pire
franchement c'est une bonne borg
c'est même une borne borg est obligé de
la faire
j'ai été obligé de la faire les mecs
c'est une buell borg
ok je me fous de la bio org
non en fait ça va
en fait ça va
alors
je préfère qualifier quatre pions
francky étrangers 4 ouais mais si je
prends c'est fou des quatre échelles
intermédiaire mais va prendre prendre
dès cette année c'est chaud
je suis un peu mal de partout je vais
faire c'est 4
ok c'est pas grave je vais faire un tour
des huit écoutant ses choix
okah le stand coup j'ai quatre envois
je n'en sur ras le petit bras au le
petit bras
ses petits bras de fer ça
ouais j'ai envie d'envoyer bah oui il
n'a pas du tout marché en fait cette
histoire parce que du coup je serais
plus protégée là bas ça n'a pas du tout
fonctionné
je suis con je suis vraiment une chance
la cua
que je vais prendre quelle est cette
bouffe voyez peut-être un poil sous
pression parce que si bush qui lie adam
prend 1,3
ça c'est protéger sa ses protégés sas a
attaqué saas et cloud et il est
peut-être en sueur qui a aidé un bien
joué ok je prends à deux donc à vrai
dire au niveau des pions ça va on a quoi
il a quatre pions hockey la sage qu'est
ce ça j'aurais peut-être pu prendre ces
deux sur échec
je vais mettre en échec comme ça
voilà temps j'ai fait un échec ici échec
je veux faire tampon f3 ou pas non je
crois pas je vais tenter d'amener un
parce que c'est le beau jeu et qui a et
b 8 ans mais j'ai plus un méga qu'une
secondes par coup j'aurais pu faire
annuler un j'aurais peut-être dû
j'aurais pu et j'aurais dû
ah je suis tombé à j'aurais dû prendre
là nul à je pensais qu'il est deux
secondes par coup mais je vais faire
tourcoing f3 mais y'a tout reprend 1,2
pour prendre 3 est prise de troie
j'aurais dû prendre là nul mais bon j'ai
voulu faire le beau jeu jusqu'au bout
et du coup c'est peut-être là que j'ai
déconné peut-être fallait faire
d'emprunt ses noms d'emprunt seront à
challans j'ai bien joué en fait j'ai pas
trouvé
moi je voulu faire le beau jeu et de
marée 1
dommage j'avais pu je sais pas je peux
pas mettre l'ordi la synthèse on en a
pris 59 face à 6 donc de toutes façons
aucun regret de ne pas avoir pris là nul
mais j'aurais pas pu
je suis sûr que j'avais mieux là je suis
sûr que là je m'étais remis bien je
trouve pas comme on gagne ça
c'est pas ça je fais quoi j'ai fait dame
b 1 300 cavaliers la dame ici
ça évite de me prend là et là tu es
complètement bloquée en fait mais
surtout avec une secondes par coup ce
que je savais pas que j'aurais peut-être
dû refaire échec en fait ce que s'ils
montent je peux prendre il prend je
prends il vient là je viens là il vient
là je matte
donc j'aurais peut-être pu encore
prendre nul mais comment on fait pour
allumer l'ordinateur quant aux rhinos
truc là puisqu'à partie était
intéressante la fin de partie était
intéressante là pour la peine ce
parti-là était cool c'était la plus
marrante en fait
ça se fait à partir fut la plus
franchement cette partie là elle était
cool c'est parti d'une borg
ces partis du bon c'est fait on s'est
fait et aller on s'est fait à les aimer
ces particules borg et ça donnait un
truc sympa à fuji catamaran bayou mieux
que nulle en fait n'a pas trouvé mais
c'est vrai que une secondes par coup
c'était trop short
j'aurais compris qu'avec une seconde
parcourront j'aurais quand même pas pris
là nul parce que faut pas abuser mais
c'est vrai que ça aurait été plus plus
malin
oui j'ai fait sur roy géant dames b3
voilà j'ai pas le temps de partir
dommage que j'ai pas eu le temps de
faire genre ouais f8 et partir là-bas
quoi
l'annoncé short est là pour la dame j'ai
pas d'autres khandan france et de ia
tura huit dames ici et damas est matin
ça j'ai vu en fait et tout reprend tout
reprendre tout reprend un cahier prend
est rien non c'est peut-être vrai
prendre là nul tu reviens défend après
dé prendre soin
ga compris à ce qu'ils étaient en 2007
quand tu dis çà çà çà çà çà çà çà et des
reprises par safran avec la tour ok mais
a fait retour à 7,2 trucks et a pas de
menace avec les blancs les noirs
du coup peut-être fait d'amener 6 manon
adieu menacé d'un adam germa toi ouais
mais fait peut-être fou j'ai quatre
échecs tout reprend j'ai quatre dames 8
dames des huit dames ici et accueille
des 5 et 17 tours à huit est peut-être
il ya des trucs comme ça quoi c'est
chaud puisque tout rage suite mandat
malgré les trucs marrants quoi ma partie
était marrant tu vois les mecs du coup
on se retrouve bon se retrouve dans une
grosse demi-heure pour à l'aréna on
essaiera de mieux jouer merci d'avoir
suivi je peux vous êtes bien amusé même
source se fait défoncer je vous dis à
très vite